Sind es Roboter oder Aliens, die uns angreifen
und uns vernichten?
Oder ist es ein gigantischer Asteroiden-Einschlag
oder gar ein Atomkrieg, der die Menschheit
endgültig auslöschen wird?!
Ein großes internationales Forschungsteam
sagt jetzt, das alles ist es nicht, sondern
drei “Pandemien”, die auch noch ineinandergreifen
und so zu einer globalen Syndemie führen.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es jeden
Tag spannende Science-Videos abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich
willkommen!
Ein bißchen erinnert mich das die Warnungen
des weltberühmten Physikers Stephen Hawking,
der uns immer wieder vor Augen gehalten hat,
welche Faktoren zur Auslöschung der Menschheit
führen könnten.
Zum Beispiel genetisch veränderte Viren,
Atomkrieg oder Künstliche Intelligenz.
Ein großes Team aus internationalen Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftlern gibt Hawking in seiner
aktuellen Studie jetzt zum Teil Recht.
Und Zwar sehen die Fachleute die Existenz
der Menschheit aktuell durch drei “Pandemien”
bedroht also weltweite Epidemien.
Das Forschungsteam hat für ihre Arbeit mehr
als 350 Quellen ausgewertet.
Und eine der eingegrenzten katastrophalen
Pandemien ist der Klimawandel - ähnlich wie
es Hawking eben einmal gesagt hatte.
Den Autoren und Autorinnen zufolge „werden
Umweltschäden ignoriert, die durch die derzeitigen
Ernährungssysteme, den Verkehr, das Städtebau
und die Landnutzung verursacht werden".
Ein Faktor also, der das Überleben der Menschheit,
riskiert - und das einzig und allein aus Machtgier
und finanziellen und wirtschaftlichen Erfolg.
Laut der Fachleute aus vierzehn Ländern könne
der Klimawandel in diesem Zusammenhang durchaus
als Pandemie gesehen werden.
Schließlich habe er weitreichende Auswirkungen
auf die Gesundheit der Menschen und zudem
auch auf die “Gesundheit” der Erde.
Passend also zur Definition des Begriffes
“Pandemie”, womit im engeren Sinne eine
Krankheit gemeint ist ist, die sich über
Länder und Kontinente ausbreitet; also nicht
örtlich begrenzt ist.
Die beiden anderen Pandemien, die das das
Überleben der Menschheit gefährden, sind
demnach zwei Krankheiten, die mit unseren
Ernährungsgewohnheiten zu tun haben.
Unterernährung zum einen und zum anderen
Fettleibigkeit.
Eigentlich ja zwei Krankheiten, die gegensätzlicher
nicht sein könnten.
Doch einer der beteiligten Forscher, Boyd
Swinburn, sieht das komplett anders: “In
Wirklichkeit werden sie beide von den gleichen
ungesunden, unangemessenen Ernährungssystemen
angetrieben, die sich (...) ausschließlich
auf das Wirtschaftswachstum konzentrieren
und die negativen Folgen im Hinblick auf die
Gesundheit sowie die Chancengleichheit ignorieren.”
Es ist ja wirklich ein verzerrtes System,
in dem wir leben.
Millionen von Menschen auf unserer Erde haben
nicht genug Nahrung und leiden unter Unterernährung.
Dagegen steht die Überproduktion, und der
enorme Konsum, der in den westlichen Ländern
zu Übergewicht und Fettleibigkeit führt.
Fast zwei Milliarden Menschen gelten weltweit
als übergewichtig oder fettleibig.
Und die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
halten auch fest, dass unsere Gesellschaft,
ebenso wie Politiker und Regierungen selbst
Ursprung dieses Problems sind.
Denn der Einfluss durch die Lebensmittelindustrie
ist groß und schlechte Ernährungsgewohnheiten
können sich so durchsetzen.
So kommen die Fachleute zu der Erkenntnis,
dass alle drei Pandemien zusammenhängen.
Denn ungesunde Ernährung macht nicht nur
uns Menschen krank, sondern fördert zudem
auch noch den Klimawandel.
Als Ursachen dafür werden in der Studie unter
anderem die Landnutzung und die Landwirtschaft
genannt.
Große Agrarbetriebe betreiben Monokulturen
und nehmen dadurch unter anderem das Abholzen
von Wäldern, schwere Umweltschäden und ein
massives Artensterben als Folgen in Kauf..
Das Autorenteam warnt davor, dass sich diese
drei Pandemien - Klimawandel, Fettleibigkeit
und Unterernährung - zu einer sogenannten
“globalen Syndemie” entwickeln.
Das bedeutet in etwa so viel wie “ineinandergreifende
Gesundheitsprobleme” - der Studie zufolge
“die größte gesundheitliche Herausforderung
für Mensch, Umwelt und Planet im 21.
Jahrhundert”.
Die Experten und Expertinnen fordern Regierungen
weltweit auf, den Einfluss großer Lebensmittelkonzerne
zu minimieren und Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Richtlinien und Verträge könnten den Ländern
dabei helfen, eine nachhaltige und gesunde
Lebensmittel-Politik auszuarbeiten.
Zudem sei es notwendig, unsere Ernährungssysteme
neu auszurichten - und zwar komplett.
Wünschenswert seien demnach beispielsweise
bessere Informationen für die Verbraucher.
Etiketten beispielsweise, die genau auflisten,
welche Zusätze in stark weiterverarbeiteten
Produkten enthalten sind.
Dazu geben die Autoren eine sehr eindrückliche
Warnung heraus :„Schönheitsreparaturen
an der Oberfläche werden nicht die Ergebnisse
liefern, die die Welt für das 21.
Jahrhunderts braucht.“
Sorry, wenn wir hier wieder, wie immer mal
wieder kritisiert, “Panik” verbreiten.
Klimawandel - Fakt oder Fiktion?
Für dieses Video hier klicken.
Anschauen und Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!